who needs mr. J yeah there was no way I
was gonna keep that look going for the
hold I'm okay
birds of prey the fantabulous
emancipation of one Harley Quinn I have
seen it I had hoped to go and see it
with Liz but timing did not work out in
our favor for that I am gonna have her
back on the channel at some point guys
it's just you know life and scheduling
and the speed of which I try and turn
these things around it's just it's a
pain but I've seen it it is a good time
I think some of the reviews I've seen
are possibly over praising it a bit I
mean the main word that I would bring up
to describe it is just fun it is a fun
movie and if you're looking for more
than that I'm not necessarily sure
you're gonna find it
and it has a few long moments in it but
honestly I just had a good time with
this thing it is undoubtedly as far as
the overall vibe and feel and pace and
energy of the thing goes this is exactly
what I wanted
Suicide Squad to be and it completely
failed to be because it is energetic
it's fun it's colorful it's peppy the
action is hard-hitting
it's not needlessly watching but like in
a situation where say you're I was in
where we would swear these people swear
uh and I yeah
I also sucker for most of these
characters I really was worried that
I've kind of gotten burnt out on Harley
she's gotten very overexposed and
honestly the last decade or so but I do
like and Margot Robbie
really gets to dig into her a lot better
here than she got to do in suicide squad
and she does get Harley she has her own
take on the character but like no that's
definitely Harley
so whatever issues were going on in
Suicide Squad weren't her fault I'm not
sure actually that any of the issues
going on in Suicide Squad where the
actress faults except for the Joker who
does not appear in here we get like gets
reference actually continuity wise I'll
just touch on that because I'll forget
to bring it up later
DC is kind of doing an interesting thing
where they have yet at least as far as I
can tell outright contradicted the
existing continuity from like Batman V
Superman or Justice League but its
referent out in Suicide Squad for that
matter but it's referenced in very broad
strokes like yeah kind of this thing
sort of happened but not a lot of direct
close knit ties which is good because it
still has the sense that these things
are happening in the same universe and
we have a sense of a timeline on it but
it's it it is its own thing which is
what I always needed to be and this
absolutely is enjoyably so so like I
mentioned with Robbie she obviously is
having an absolute blast playing this
part there's a lot of fourth wall
breaking but it's established very early
on and it's sort of the flow this entire
thing is being presented as a story
Harley is telling so it makes the fourth
wall breaking a little bit less gimmicky
than I had feared it was going to be
knowing that it happened in here so that
worked for me pretty well um the other
characters I mean like these are
characters I just like I like Huntress I
really like Black Canary
I love Renee Montoya and I haven't read
a ton of stuff with Cassandra Kanan but
I've always liked her that having been
said Cassandra Cain bears the least
resemblance to her comic book
counterpart actually bears almost none
they basically just pulled the name the
other characters have been altered and
shifted and rejiggered a little bit but
are fairly identifiable as their comic
book characters and all well played
as well including Cassandra Cain as much
as she is not a representation of the
character from the comics she's well
performed too and everybody really I was
gonna say bring their a-game that might
be again overselling it everybody brings
their fun game because you know when you
with actors you can tell when they're
coming in like okay serious work here
and then you can tell when actors come
come in and go yeah this is just for the
paycheck and you can tell when actors
come in and go yeah this one's fun I
can't believe I'm getting paid to do
this and that is the that last one is
the vibe we get off of this from pretty
much everybody who is in it if I were to
pick a favorite I'm kind of partial to
Renee Montoya cuz I really like her as a
character anyway and I've always liked
Rosie Perez
I always kind of felt that she was sort
of undervalued as an actress and the
film has fun sort of playing up the
overly hard-boiled almost cliche
storyline sort of the you know the rogue
cop thing for for Montoya it has fun
sort of jabbing at that a little bit the
take on Black Canary is is interesting
that actress has a really captivating
presence and and as for Huntress she's
she doesn't get a ton of lines yet a lot
is brought across with those few lines
because of the performance that gets
delivered and we spend by far the most
time with Harley and a decent amount of
time with Cassandra Cass usually
referred to in this we've also got the
villain who well there's a couple of
villains in this but the primary villain
we've got Ewan McGregor playing black
mask he was fun too until he wasn't but
I mean that in a good way and what I
mean by that is he starts out very just
almost cartoonish you know as a villain
you know this sort of overblown yo it's
fun movie don't take him too seriously
but then he's got a couple of scenes
later on that you're like oh oh you're
not fun you're you're dangerous like
you're unhinged and dangerous and like
not in a fun way and instead of feeling
like a they drop the ball in the
character and he stopped being fun it
was more of a yeah you think this guy's
fun he's not and it was a transition
totally worked for me I dug it I also
really like to stake on Victor Zsasz not
my new favorite by any means
Gotham Victor Zsasz all the way every
day forever but I really did find this
take interesting he he has a very
off-putting unsettling just slightly
off-kilter delivery to a lot of his
lines and there's this vibe between him
and black mask that reads to me very
much as honestly a possibly unrequited
crush the possibly he's just on the
unrequited the crush I think he's
definitely there he's he's got that
level of nobody understands Roman but me
nobody can protect him me that sort that
sort of possessiveness that whether it's
intended to actually read as as having a
romantic crush on him is certainly
possessive male romantically gay
romantically gay coded in terms of the
level of obsession he has with doing
right by by black mask by Roman and also
like he seems to get some enjoyment out
of nudging him into unstable areas like
he encourages the guys worst instincts
so you also get the vibe off of his as
that part of what he really likes about
working for Roman is it allows him to do
all of horrible things he really wants
to do so he will nudge
Roman in encourage ya it's not like he's
manipulating him into doing something he
wouldn't do otherwise but he absolutely
is encouraging the worst possible
behavior out of Roman because it gives
him license to do incredibly terrible
stuff so I thought was a pretty good
take on zazz I rather enjoyed him quite
a bit as well the action was actually
really good
there's strategic use of slow motion at
a few points which is kind of become
standard in action movies right now but
it's well deployed and more important
than anything else this thing has
something that to me matters possibly
more than anything else in a good action
scene which is the hits look and sound
like they hurt and that for me sells it
a lot if you can avoid over rapid
cutting and the end part of its cheating
I guess with the slow-mo but they
haven't enough long sort of take so you
can really see how the hit is being
delivered and mmm the hits hurt and I
love that I think the one thing I would
sort of knock it on as far as the action
goes is I feel like the climactic fight
didn't wasn't really enough of an
escalation as far as combat had been it
was just against more you know it was
just these women fighting more guys in a
slightly more colourful and ridiculous
setting but the nature of the combat
didn't change it was the same sort of
fighting we've been seeing up to this
point which is not to say that it was
bad it's just I don't think that's
simply throwing more guys at them was
enough to escalate the the threat and
the fight to have it feel more like a
climax it still worked and the final
confrontation with Roman I actually
quite liked including how that pans out
at the very end I won't spoil it but I
did dig that a lot I like how this sets
up the birds of prey to be their own
thing
actually possibly even be their own
thing absent Harley Quinn which I
definitely appreciate cuz I like the
birds of prey and as much as I did have
fun with this movie they should not be
shackled to Harley Quinn and they should
be allowed to spread their wings oh god
why did I say that anyways this was a
good time this was fun this was
high-energy this was entertaining
there's a tiny lull in the middle that's
mostly built around Harley and Casandra
sort of bonding and getting to know each
other and was necessary structure wise
but I don't know I was gonna say it goes
on too long I'm not sure it does it just
didn't hold my interest nearly as much
as the stuff that had led up to it and
the stuff that came after it's just a
little bit of a lull in the middle but
these are minor complaints you know that
and and the climax the rest of it it's
just fun it is
raucous it is intense it is hard-hitting
it is energetic it is colorful it is a
dang good time at the movies birds of
prey you've seen it what you think about
it whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments and
let's talk about it there's a bunch of
stuff to do as well you can support me
on patreon and help me you know keep the
lights on around here plus you know the
usual like subscribe share this around
tell your friends all that stuff or
don't you don't have to I'm not gonna
tell you what to do end of the day
you're the council I'm just running on
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]